you
hello everyone and welcome to our next
presentation entitled generation and
application of 3d organized cell culture
models using humans induced pluripotent
stem cells for drug discovery which will
be presented by ryan higgs associate
director of the stem and primary cell
group at AstraZeneca I'm Roland others
from thermo Fisher Scientific and I will
be your moderator for today's
presentation before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this is an
interactive event so we encourage you to
participate by submitting any questions
you may have at any time during this
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your question into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen well answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you are having trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please use the ask a question box to let
us know of any technical difficulties
with that I would now like to introduce
you to Ryan Hicks brian is currently
associate director of the stem and
primary sense primary cell group at
AstraZeneca Ryan's group is responsible
for the generation engineering and
differentiation of IPS cells
adult stem cells and primary cells for
assay development target validation it
finding it to lead lead optimization and
phenotypic screening activities cellular
models are generated in 2d and 3d
culture systems and part of the model
development work includes using precise
genome modification techniques to
introduce gene knockouts
knocking mutations or endogenous
reporters into the ICS cells the group's
work primarily focuses on AstraZeneca
cardiovascular metabolic renal and
respiratory disease areas ryan joined
AstraZeneca in 2001 and has been based
in sweden for the past eight years prior
to working in sweden ryan worked as the
associate director of the cell and
protein reagents group at AstraZeneca in
Alderley Park UK with responsibilities
within the cell and protein disciplines
Ryan received his degree in medical
biochemistry from the University of
Birmingham UK and his PhD in
biochemistry and molecular biology from
the University of Leeds UK in 2000
one and with that I would now like to
turn the presentation over to Ryan
thank you very much for the introduction
as you stated my name is Ryan Hicks and
I would like to talk today about the
generation and application of 3d
organoids cell culture models using
human induced pluripotent stem cells for
drug discovery the way I'd like to do
this is to first off tell you a little
bit about AstraZeneca and about the stem
of primary cell team that I lead and
also give you some background on the
types of things that our team does i
will then move on to talk about 3d
organoids and i would do this by using
our 3d kidney organoid model as an
example to highlight the work we've done
in the orgonite space this will include
why we are generating 3d kidney
organoids how we are generating them and
validating them and also how we use them
in a drug discovery setting
so AstraZeneca is a global
biopharmaceutical company with around
60,000 employees and we have three main
focus areas and these are cardiovascular
renal and metabolic oncology and
respiratory inflammation and
autoimmunity we also have opportunistic
areas and these include infection and
neuroscience each of our focus areas is
driven by our innovative medicine
biotech units or IMATS and these eye
meds are supported by centralized
departments including discovery safety
metabolism and discovery sciences of
which I am apart Discovery Sciences is a
central group that provides
state-of-the-art support for HID finding
lead optimization target validation and
this is for all therapeutic research
areas across AstraZeneca and we do this
through partnering with each of the
therapeutic areas on the projects that
they have within discovery scientists we
have a number of different centralized
groups and examples include sample
management at Thunder our compound
collection high-throughput screening
protein structure and biophysics and
several others the department within
which I belong is called discovery
biology and our mission is to be at the
innovating front of science and
technology to deliver reagents assays
and disease models to discover new
targets and medicines our discover
biology group is located across four
sites two of these in the UK one in
Sweden and one in the US the stem and
Primus L group which I lead is based in
Gothenburg and is a global group
supporting areas across AstraZeneca and
we focus on generating cells and
cellular models that fit with the focus
areas of AstraZeneca so these include
hepatic lobe EMU
kidney pancreas cardiac adipose and
neuro and then generating these models
we use many supporting technologies and
some of these include precise genome
editing and we use this to Danette eclis
manipulate ourselves and these are
technologies like CRISPR we also culture
ourselves in a variety of formats and
these can range from 2d through 3d micro
physiological systems and humanized mini
organs and by that I mean tissues that
have been decellularized and then
ReCellular eyes with stem cells we also
use techniques such as high content
imaging and next-generation sequencing
and this is in support of both the
quality control and the validation our
models as well as looking at their
function for screening and application
in a drug discovery setting
it's also very important to the group to
have an external presence and the way we
do that is to having postdocs within our
lab and students including PhD students
and master students and we also have a
number of collaborations and a lot of
this is pointing towards publications
and presenting at external conferences
in this slide I'd like to give some
examples of how our team provides stem
cells in drug discovery these models are
all IPS derived some of which have been
manipulated using precise genome editing
and they grown in single-cell 2d and 3d
formats so starting in the top left hand
corner in the blue box we had a project
team that was looking at an anti
inflammatory response in macrophages
this was mediated through salt induced
kinase or seek now seek comes in three
isoforms so the team approached us as
they wanted to know which of these
isoforms was driving their desired
phenotype so what our team did is that
first we looked to generate a
differentiation protocol to take our IPS
cells through Darren past monocytes to
macrophages so once we developed a
protocol to generate macrophages from
our IPS cells we then applied precise
genome editing using CRISPR to modify
our IPS cells and what we did was to
systematically make catalytically dead
versions of each of the seek isoforms in
different cell lines so that the cell
would express each seek isoform but the
isoform itself will be catalytically
inactive
we then take each of these isoforms
together with the parental cell line and
differentiated them down to macrophages
and then applied them in the project
team assay and then looked at their
response to different compounds and from
this we could identify which of the
isoforms was responsible for driving the
phenotype and this enabled the project
team to direct their chemistry against
the right isoform of seek to be able to
drive new medicines against the anti
inflammatory response
the second example I would like to talk
about is in the bottom left hand corner
in the pink box and this is in the
cardiac space and here the project team
was interested in finding agents that
could specifically induce the
proliferation of cardiac progenitor
cells so again taking IPS cells
regenerated cardiac progenitor cells and
applied them into a passe to be able to
measure the proliferation rates so we
wanted to measure the basal
proliferation rate and that in the graph
is shown in blue to show the
proliferation rate of the cells in
normal conditions and then in the
presence of a positive control in this
case fgf to see the maximal
proliferation rate we then ran a screen
using small molecules to see which small
molecules we could find that would
induce proliferation of our IPS derived
cardiac cells and then counter
screen.this against other cellular
models to try and find compounds that
were specific for proliferation of
cardiac cells
the third example is in the pancreatic
space so we have an entire an interest
in diabetes and so protocols that can
help us generate pancreatic beta-cells
are very interesting to us a useful tool
to aid the development of protocols as
well as having online QC and supporting
in screening of compounds is to have an
endogenous reporter tag in that cell
line in this case for our pancreatic
cells we genetically modified our IPS
cells to contain a GFP reporter
downstream of the NK X 6.1 gene an
important factor that you should see
coming up along the differentiation root
of IPS cells
towards pancreatic beta cells here you
can see in the images on the top row the
differentiation of the parameter line
down the pancreatic lineage and the
expression of NK X 6.1 as done by
staining and imaging which we need to
terminate the culture and the image and
fix whereas in the bottom panel you can
see with a GFP reporter line you can see
GFP expression together with NK X 6.1
showing that the reporter can give you a
live readout of NK X 6.1 expression and
I will talk more about the generation of
endogenous reporters linked in the
presentation
finally on this slide you can see a kid
model and here we are generated 3d
kidney organoids using a reporter line
and apply this to a number of projects
and it is these organoids that I'll
focus on in this presentation so in this
slide I just wanted to give you a bit of
background on what we wanted to use
these organoids for and what features we
were looking for so in the kidney space
we've worked on a variety of kidney cell
types generating kidney cells from IPS
in 2d formats to decode cultures and
also in 3d formats and is this 3d format
that I shall let talk about today
these organoids we have we have applied
in a multitude of different settings and
this includes disease modeling and here
we took cells in normal and diseased
states using either culture conditions
they get the disease state or using
precise genome editing to genetically
modify the cells to see a disease
phenotype we also use them for target
identification purposes supporting
activities like phenotypic screening of
these organized self identify new
targets we also apply our organoids to
target validation activities
so taking targets the divisor being
identified internally or externally for
example from the literature and then
validating these targets and by
validating in this context I mean to
confirm the target that has been
identified is responsible for the
disease state or that if you modulate
that target it responsible for causing a
disease State or returning that cell
back to a normal state
we also use them in a safety and
metabolism setting as well to look at
the profile of molecules that we are
developing so for the phenotypes that we
look at I've listed just a few of the
features that we might look for and
these include cell specific uptake or
target engagement or it could be things
like clearance of a compound or its
toxic effect the key requirements of the
model are that it must be translatable
so the reading we get in our in vitro
setting translates through to the in
vivo setting ultimately it needs to
translate to the patient setting so that
the readout that we are seeing in the in
vitro model is what we would see in the
patient setting so we have a predictive
model it also needs to be reproducible
we need a robust technique that we avoid
false positives and false negatives and
we can trust the data time after time
all of this is for the ultimate aim of
driving our drug discovery projects
so now I'd like to
a little bit about what has driven us
and driven the need for us to generate
these in vitro 3d organoid models
if I take it at a top level
for looking at chronic kidney disease
there is a very high prevalence it's
estimated that over ten percent of the
world population is affected by chronic
kidney disease and indeed the mortality
rates are seen to increase so between
1990 and 2013 we have seen a doubling in
mortality rates and if you look within
the UK chronic kidney disease kills more
people than breast cancer lung colon and
skin cancer combined
in terms of treatments there are very
limited options for chronic kidney
disease treatment and so there is a high
unmet medical need to advance new
medicines in the field of chronic kidney
disease and for that we need in vitro
models to help discover those medicines
so looking more specifically about why
we need an in vitro 3d kidney model as
we've talked about there some general
needs in drug discovery for models in
terms of the need to be translatable
rapid and reproducible and also I've
talked about some of the activities that
need these tag identification and target
validation and use in screening as well
as safety applications so what is
driving the need for 3d models so what
we're seeing is that there are 2d models
in place today but many of these show a
lack of translate ability where the
response you see in these 2d models does
not recapitulate in the patient setting
or is not predictive of other models
there can be a number of reasons of why
these two models don't translate well
some of these include a lack of
expression of key genes and proteins
that you expect to see in the model or
in the patient setting that do not come
up these models are often generated with
immortalized cell lines and so if you
want to see a gene that's not there you
have to over express your target and
this is not ideal from a biology point
of view nor is it ideal for my model
point of view that you have to generate
a number of different cells to generate
your different models these models can
also be derived from primary cells this
does give some advantages but also the
donor cells from primary primary cells
from patients you do see donor to donor
variability their supply can be limited
and they can also differentiate really
rapidly once they're out of the patient
and so do not resemble how they looked
when they were in the in vivo setting a
final point is that by definition a 2d
model doesn't contain the 3d structures
that you see within the kidney and so if
you're wanting to look at some
structural components then that's not
possible and you would need a 3d in
vitro model for that stem cells do have
a number of limitations but they also
offer a route to generating improved
models of this in a 3d setting
[Applause]
this slide is just to highlight what our
3d kidney organoids look like so you
have that in your mind when I go through
this presentation so in the middle of
this slide you can see a diagram a
picture sorry of one of our orgonites
where it has been stained so in the
light blue staining you can see wt1
which was a surrogate marker for
podocytes you can also see in red ltl
staining which is a surrogate marker for
our proximal tubule cells and in green
you can see CD 31 as a surrogate marker
for endothelial cells so in our
organized we are seeing the Assembly of
a clustering of different cell types and
cell types that we would want to be seen
in our killing organoid
so I'd now like to move on and tell you
a bit about how we built our model and
that I touched on earlier a great
advantage to model building is to have a
reporter cell line and this can give you
live information both on our how your
IPS cell line is progressing down the
lineage for development of protocols and
also for QC purposes and so the first
step in what we did was to generate a
threatened trip or tur line as we talked
about we did this using precise genome
editing and we're fortunate with an
Astra Zeneca to have a very strong
toolbox of precise genome editing
capability and we have a number of
things in that toolbox that we apply to
our stem cells for different projects
and these include the knockout of genes
to remove the expression and this can be
simple straight knockouts or conditional
knockouts that are inducible we also do
knockings whereby we insert DNA
sequences for example to create disease
mutations within the IPS line and this
we did to make for example the
functional dead mutant that I talked
about earlier for seek what I'll focus
on more is about how we've used it to
introduce endogenous reporter tags and
that will come up in later slides and we
also have CRISPR forms that modulate
expression so CRISPR I and a technology
whereby we can use CRISPR to either
inhibit the expression of a gene or to
activate its expression of a gene
so when considering the markers we
wanted to highlight to generate our
kidney cell types of interest we thought
about what genes along the route the
generation towards our kidney specific
cells did we want to see so starting in
the top left hand corner the markers we
would like to see in our
undifferentiated stem cell and going
down the lineage towards kidney
precursor cells and then ultimately to
the different cell types we would want
to see in the kidney and also genes we
did not want to see Express if they were
going down the incorrect route and this
diagram shows that flow and the first
point we wanted to see a marker was at
the kidney progenitor stage and here we
chose 6-2 as our reporter so what we
wanted to do here was to introduce an
endogenous 4sm protein downstream of the
6-2 gene such that when 60 was expressed
we could also see the expression of a
fluorescent protein and the cell would
change color
a single reporter we also wish to make
some double reporter cells so that we
could see the tail change cover again as
it matured down towards our cell type of
interest in this case a pata site as
indicated by the star and for this we
chose nephron so again what we did is
you wanted to insert a different
fluorescent reporter downstream of
nephron so that when this second gene
expressed a different fluorescent marker
would also Express and the cells would
change color again and these reporter
lines will help us to define and refine
our differentiation protocol as well as
giving a good QC to see how well our
organoid generation was progressing
on the technical side of exactly how we
built these lines I've just added this
slide to show the CRISPR system which I
believe most people are familiar with
but in brief you use the cast line and
the nuclease to cut to your DNA and if
you also add the presence of some donor
DNA you can get that to integrate
specifically at a site and introduce
that new DNA on the right hand side I've
given a schematic of that donor DNA and
what you can see is it's composed of
flanking regions on either side sharing
homology to the area and where we wanted
to insert it we also have a to a site
and that helps to have the mRNA cleave
into two parts when you're expressing
the genes and this is important to us
because we want to see six-two
expression and also GFP expression but
we do not want the to fuse together
because we don't want to interfere with
the six-two expression so that was why
we introduced the to a site then we have
the fluorescent reporter and following
this we have an antibiotic resistance
cassette flanked by loxp sites so this
serves the function that when we're
getting integration we can use the
antibiotics resistance to help select
the clones with integration and once
we've selected our Crohn's we can use
query companies to remove that cassette
and avoid any unwanted side effects of
having the antibiotic cassette in our
cell line of interest
we did a similar thing with nephron and
we did this in using multiple different
reporters in single and dual reporter
lines to give us a suite of cells that
we could use to monitor our
differentiation when generating our
reporter cell lines we want to make sure
that they are validated and we looked at
a different a few different areas here
so looking at pluripotency so
differentiating the line down into the
different lineages to make sure it is
still pluripotent that it can
differentiate into the different germ
layers we also look for expression in
the IPS cell of markers that show it is
in still a stem cell state and we can do
this by imaging and also flow analysis
we also perform a quite a bit of
sequence analysis to ensure that the
integration of our cassette was accurate
was faithful and that we didn't see any
off-target cutting von CRISPR or
off-target integration of the cassettes
genomic stability is also very important
to ensure that the cell line has
maintained its karyotype throughout the
cloning process and also maintains
karyotype throughout its culture
a further home
nation was to see that when we are
differentiating our reporter lines down
the kidney lineage towards podocytes
that we could see the co expression of
the reporter gene of interest together
whether fluorescent reporter as well so
what we did was to take our IPS reporter
lines and differentiate them using the
protocols to hand and monitor by qPCR
and by imaging the expression of our
desired target proteins and on the right
hand side you can see a graph of one
such measure where we have looked at
mRNA expression levels of our six too
and see how that correlates with GFP
expression levels monitored by flow
cytometry and we can see that the two
are correlating nicely so we were happy
that we have generated reporter lines
that were working nicely in our hands
okay so just to give you a few details
about the protocol that we applied to
differentiate our IPS reporting lines
down the kidney lineage towards our 3d
organoids so we start with a initial 2d
phase culturing the cells for 10 days in
2d after which time we harvest at day 10
and then we see these cells into a grow
well plates and we like to use agrawal
plates as this gives us a very precise
control both on the cell number within
the organ ID and so the size that
organoid will become and we keep cells
in this every well plate for 2 days to
let them form these organoids after
which we harvest the organ loads from
the plate and then we grow them in
suspension for at least 12 days to
mature to the 3d organoids
we have several QC steps along the way
to ensure we're getting reproducible
results and the great QC as we said is
to use our reporter lines so in the
bottom right hand corner of this slide
you can see images of two such reporter
lines the one on the left hand side is
showing a reporter of nephron which is a
red reporter and you can see expression
of our red reporter and the bottom right
hand is a second reporter line whereby a
nephron is followed by a green
fluorescent protein and then you can see
expression of GFP in our orgonites
what you can also see is the expression
is located in certain areas within the
organize and I will come to this later
on
this slide is just to quickly show some
further QC using electron microscopy of
our organized and in that you can see
features that you would like to see
within the kidney appearing in our organ
ID so here with on panel a with
transmission electron microscopy you can
see images of day 35 alba noids showing
features you would like to see such as
tight junctions and also so maybe some
primitive foot processes from paula
sites and in the lower panel a scanning
electron microscopy images of the
surface of the organoid again when you
can see features that you could see
perhaps look perhaps resemble slit
diaphragms of the glomerulus
okay so I've given you some details of
how remain the organoids and I want to
move on just to tell you a little bit
more about that but more so about the QC
of these orgonites
and what things we consider when we're
generating them to be able to apply them
to a drug discovery setting so we have
published our protocols and you can find
this in the publication shown on screen
and in here you'll find details on the
protocol and you'll also find further
information on things like single cell
next-generation sequencing that we've
performed and also further imaging
analysis of these orgonites
so when generating advanced models and
thinking about applying them to a drug
discovery setting we need to keep some
key components in mind and I've listed
these on the circle on the left-hand
side so just to touch on a few of these
thinking about culture format thinking
about how we grow ourselves either going
in suspension or the growing apparently
are they as individual cells or as Ilias
clusters and can these be adapted to
different formats and this is to support
their growth and development but also
making sure that they are amenable to
the technologies we're using to assay
them we need to consider the scale at
which we can generate these cells so to
what extent can we scale up or scale out
our methods to keep to keep the method
faithful but also to keep the cell
numbers and reach cell numbers needed
for the screen that we would like to do
we have to have a quality model and by
this I mean that the readout that we're
reading in the in vitro assay how well
can we measure this and does this
readout does this measure give a good
surrogate measure for the situation or
the response that we'd like to see in
the patient we need to be able to
modulate the system and by this I mean
two forms of modulation modulating the
system itself
so how amenable is this system to
modulation by genome editing or by
conditioning the quarters in which
you're growing it in to represent the
patient physiology such as hypoxia or
high glucose and also modulation of the
system by different perturbance so we're
seeing an increasing range now of
entities available to us to modulate
cells that goes beyond small molecules
so we have things like modified RNA
antisense oligo s-- inhibitory RNAs
viruses antibodies secreted proteins and
the CRISPR system so how well does our
model fit with with these modalities to
be able to affect it to read out
robustness so we have a touchstone a
high need that it is accurate and
consistent and we need appropriate
positive and negative controls so we
know how well our system is working and
that we are eliminating false positives
and false negatives and finally cost and
this is a factor we need a system that
is affordable and they become running a
screening context to the throughput and
turnaround times needed
so considering some practicalities of
working with 3d organoids and here I'm
thinking especially about readouts in
the imaging space so here there are
several considerations and limitations
we need to be aware of when using our
organoids so if you look in the top left
hand corner you can see our 10k
organoids and these are organoids with
10,000 cells inside them and these range
from about 300 to 500 micrometers in
diameter over on the top right-hand side
you can see some organize you mate which
are 1k so these have 1000 cells inside
them and these have a diameter of around
150 to 300 micrometers
images of these orgonites it's tempting
to think that you're looking through the
middle but using the technologies we
have we are quite limited to the depth
at which we can image these organoids
and this is influenced by a number of
factors including the focal points of
your reader the depth at which your
imaging agents can penetrate into the
organoid and the intensities in which
they read back or which your imager can
read the deeper they penetrate into the
organoid it's important to remember this
when looking at the images now these are
cross-sections not through the middle of
the organoid but rather of the edge of
the organoid as shown in the top middle
diagram in the lower panel we're seeing
images that have come from different
types of analysis of those images using
our confocal so we can use features such
as max projection so taking a number of
stacked images and amalgamating them
together to give an overall image of
what we're seeing throughout the slice
of the organoid that we were looking at
and in this first image in the bottom
left hand corner you're seeing an
amalgamated readout of the GFP
fluorescence you can see following the
nephron reporter
alternatively we can look at individual
sections if you wish to look in more
detail about what's happening at the
different levels and also follow
features as they move through the
organoid we're constantly evolving and
adapting our 3d organoid with drug
discovery in mind and here i've tried to
list a few of these developments that
we've made so stippling sticking with
the imaging theme it's very important
that our organized are in a fixed
position on the bottom of the plate as I
described in the method our organoids
are generated in suspension so we needed
to develop methods that would stick our
organoids down to the bottom of the
imaging plate whilst retaining their 3d
structure in the bottom left-hand panel
you can see some bright field images of
our kidney organoid stick to the bottom
of the plate much of the structure
remains although we do see some cell
migration out from the organoid but we
are able to stick our organoids to a
plate the attachment is random so we're
not directing whereabouts in the plate
that it's sticking down and as such when
we're coming to image the plate and
image the organoids we want to make sure
that the images we are capturing are the
interesting ones and ones are the
organoids rather than the empty spaces
between so here we have developed
methods where we can do some searchable
functions where the plate can be quickly
read and identify where these organoids
are and importantly remember which
organoid is stuck where and this is very
good for when we're reading the plate
again and again and you can also come
back at a later time pointer to reimage
that plate and you can look at the same
organoid and see what's happening to
that exact organ always over a time and
also following treatment
so this is enabled us to generate an
asset where we can rapidly image the
points of interest within a plate in a
384 well plate format and a model which
you can image multiple times over the
course of a treatment here a final slide
and some of the techniques were using to
validate our organoids and validate what
we're doing so I've spoken a lot about
imaging and you see in the top
right-hand corner some images of
sections through and organoid and here
we're sharing features stained with LTL
to show the tubular cells stained with
wt1
for our pata site cells and staying with
CD 31 in green to show endothelial cells
and if we look at the CD one staining
you can see vessel like structures
forming and you can see branches forming
off these vessels and you can also see a
potential for a lumen to start forming
so seeing some nice features forming
throughout our organizer
in addition to imaging you can see how
they're using immunohistochemistry on
our organoids
to look at structural features
throughout and from this that you can
see in the organoid that in the center
we're not getting a necrotic core we're
seeing cell features that we would see
throughout the organize next generation
sequencing is also a powerful tool that
we have applied to our organize it is
both in the single cell space to see
which cell types are within the
organized and what genes are expressing
and also using bulk RNA seek on the
organoids as they develop over 0 10 20
30 40 and 50 days to see which genes are
present and absent and when they go up
and when they go down and this is very
useful when looking at our organized
especially if you have a target in mind
because we can quickly check if the
target is present what level the RNA
expression is and at which time point
it's increasing and decreasing and all
of these things are giving us confidence
that we have a validated model
so now to move on to some examples of
using these 3d kidney organoids the
first example is looking at drug
clearance so here we're thinking about
looking at transport activity in real
models for drug clearance and on the top
you can see a pictorial diagram of the
kidney going down through to the
proximal tibial cells of which the
project team is interested and in there
we can see this the transporters that
the team are specifically interested in
notably oat one owed three and two
so the team are interested in these
because they are involved in the process
of elimination of drugs from the
basolateral membrane moving them from
the bloodstream they do have models that
exist today and there's a number of cell
sources for these including immortalized
cells like hex and MDC k where you are
over expressing the transporter of
interest but that's not ideal for
reasons I've mentioned earlier there
also you can use fresh or cry preserved
RP Tex
I think these are seen as the gold
standard for in vitro work but they do
have a higher theological I think
relevance than the immortalized lines
but the transport expression can quickly
down regulate and they do see batch to
batch variations so as an opportunity
here to apply our 3d organoids to
validate this model so the project team
came to us wanting to see if our
organoids would work in this system and
in the blue box is highlighted some of
the requirements they put on us and i've
touched on these earlier and so what we
did is we first looked at the RNA
expression data from our organoids and
this is shown in the bottom right hand
corner so we can see an upregulation of
the key genes that were interested in in
our day 31 organoids as compared to our
day 10
in the middle image at the bottom you
can see their structures so the interest
is in the proximal tubular cells and
using LTL we're staining for these and
we can see in the top right hand corner
of the image a ring of these cells looks
like they're forming a tubular with a
lumen in the middle and also flowing
down cell staining the e-cat hearing
which could be an indication of forming
further tubular structures like the
distal tubule so from initial looking at
the data it looked like we had the
transporters xpress that we would like
to see
so the experimental setup that we talked
was to take these day 31 organoids and
then in two different assays look at
either OCT 2 or oh one or three and the
way we would do that was to take a
substrate that was fitzy lay wood so we
could image it and then see how this was
taken up into organoids in the presence
or absence of inhibitors and this
ideally would be done in live imaging so
we could see a substrate being taken up
but there are a lot of limitations here
so we also saw if we would have to do
fixed imaging so where we would fix and
permeable eyes and then stain the
organoids as well in the assay so this
slide shows some of the initial data on
the 32 and oh one and three substrate
uptake so if you look at the top
left-hand image you can see when we add
substrate to the organoids they go
bright green indicating that the orb
enoyed have taken up the substrate and
in the bottom left-hand where you see
the same experiment with the impress of
an inhibitor there is much reduced
uptake of the substrate into the
organoids and the same is true with the
oat 1/3 a specific substrate again
seeing good uptake into the organoids
and in the presence of an inhibitor that
that is being inhibited and on the right
hand side you're seeing an untreated
control where there's no substrate added
and you might be able to see a faint
green background and that's coming from
the nephron GFP reporter so from this we
could see we're getting a specific
uptake from the channels into the
organoids and it looked like it was
going into specific compartments but we
couldn't tell from this imaging so this
slide we're looking at a closer look at
the organoids using both the green and
the red channel so in the top left-hand
panel this is the live imaging where you
can see proximal tubules staining in the
middle you can see in the bright green
where the substrate is going in and with
the dark green where the
nephron GFP reporter is coming up in the
bottom panel you see the fixed cells of
the fixed organoids so in the bottom
middle panel you can see again where the
LTL cells are stained you cannot see any
substrate because of the cells have been
fixed permeable eyes and then go back in
and so that subject is leaked out but
you can see where the GFP is expressing
so if you look at the image on the
bottom right hand side we're seeing Co
expression of the gfp reporter with the
separate prototype marker wt1
and in the top right hand corner we have
a nice image whereby you can see red
staining for proximal cells and also
where the is growing bright green that
is where the substrate is being taken up
slide says much the same thing whereby
we're doing the same experiments but
with oat 1/3 again you can see we're
getting a specific uptake of the dye
into the organoids and into a specific
compartments so if I just point you to
the top right hand corner you can see a
substrate specific uptake into the
organoid and it's being taken up by the
proximal tubular cells rather than the
prada size so to summarize we're seeing
uptake of the substrate in a specific
manner it can be inhibited by the
specific inhibitors and we can see it's
being taken up by the correct cell type
so that's all positives
unfortunately quantification is very
challenging to see how much dye is taken
up and also its uptake rather than
transport across the lumen so we can't
do any next flux studies but we do see
this as a good start model for drug
clearance the second example I would
like to give is looking at a toxicity to
see how people a Guinness effect drug
toxicity
so the data I'm showing here is from a
poster presented at Euro tox and here
what we tried to do was unravel the
toxicity may toxicity induced by people
on gamma agonists using our IPS derived
kidney organoids and transcriptomic
analysis so what we did here was to take
our organoids and apply peeper agonists
and then harvest after six hours all
dose again over nine days and then
harvest after nine days to see how the
people agonist had affected the kidney
organoid and the readout for that was
transcriptome it's
so from this the preliminary PCR data
shows that the kidney organoid did
demonstrate Doug induced gene expression
changes and these genes were associated
with kidney toxicity water reabsorption
and ion transport as well as known
people gamma target genes it was a
little surprising perhaps that there
were fewer significant changes in the
transcriptome analysis than we might
have anticipated but analysis is still
ongoing but interestingly we did find a
common gene target that was regulated
both by the classic peopIe Venus
rosiglitazone and pig liver zone and
that's shown in the graph on the right
so to summarize here although this work
is early and analysis is still ongoing
we have identified a solium amino acid
transporter as a pituitary par gamma
target and that's found to be expressed
in the Renewable cells and we believe
our data indicates that the IPS derived
kidney organoids may provide a platform
to detect peep are gamma induced
responses in the toxicity model there
are certainly opportunities to develop
this model using things like single-cell
analysis to be able to deconvolution
affected by the toxicity but ultimately
this is a good step forward in the
identification of some safety biomarkers
so now just moving towards some closing
remarks first just to summarize things
where we are with the 3d kidney or Lloyd
work so for the 3d model itself I
believe we have demonstrated
reproducibility of our model we've
adapted it to a drug discovery setting
allowing screening we're seeing the
emergence of 3d in vivo like structures
and we have a performed extensive
characterization of these orgonites
looking at function phenotype using
imaging and omics data and I think we've
given some examples in the safety space
of how we've applied days
we've also used these with CRISPR
modified IPS cells looking at disease
mutations and also looking at them for
target identic a tion and validation I
was not able to talk about these today
but look forward to talking about these
perhaps at future presentations we've
also use them for biomarker discovery
and in project screening
summary for 3d organoids overall i think
we and certainly many other groups
external to AstraZeneca have achieved a
lot so far in this field but there's
still a lot left to do not least getting
further data and evidence that the 3d
models are indeed superior in their
functionality and translate ability
compared to 2d models there are lots of
reasons of why they should be better but
I think more data to show that they are
is needed we certainly need to improve
the scale up so that it could be applied
for higher throughput screaming we also
need to improve the culture so not only
to develop the organoids but also the
technologies that were using to measure
the output from these orgonites
our organoids are showing some key
markers and some emerging structures but
they are far from mature so work to
further mature these organoids
is certainly needed one possibility
would be to apply these organoids into
micro physiological systems to introduce
features like flow so this should put
things like shear stress onto the
organoids and hopefully improve
maturation as well as giving us
alternative functional readout so
this is all with a function on
developing new medicine and also
publishing great science and with that
it just remains for me to thank they're
very many people involved in this work
across AstraZeneca and our external
collaborators to thank the organizers
once again for the opportunity to
present to you today and also to thank
you for your attention
and I will now hand back to Roman thank
you Brian thank you so much for that
very insightful presentation will now
begin the live Q&A portion of this
webinar so again if you have a question
you would like to ask please do so by
clicking on the ask a question drop-down
box located on the far left of your
presentation window type in your
question that appears into the box and
then click the send button okay so let's
get started we have a few minutes for
questions so we do have a number of
questions that are in and I'll start off
here with Brian from a just a purely
practical standpoint and based on your
experience what should newcomers to the
fields be aware of before stepping into
the space of organoid culture what basic
advice can you give them I think going
in with your eyes open certainly it is
it is culture everyday and it is it is
hard work so stem cells are not the
easiest cells to work with and they need
a lot of attention and then we're moving
into organoids we are just complicating
things immensely so I think govern with
your eyes open in terms of the time it
will take you there are costs involved
as well it is not a cheap culture to do
and then also I think you need to have
the question in mind that you wish to
answer so what is it that you answer
wish to answer and what is that the
organoids would do that you are lacking
at the moment so I think you need to go
with the key question in mind so that
you can answer that with your organoid I
would say very good I have another
question for you here this is about
actually a generation of IPS themselves
and we have somebody here asking about
the methodologies that you use for
generating your IPs and why you have
selected those specific methodologies
so I guess there are a number of
different ways to generate this question
is pointing at I P s from somatic cells
so there are a number of different
methods to do that and they're advancing
all the time
I would say that our lab does that I
would also say that there are some very
good lab some providers externally to do
that very well as well so we do some de
novo generation of IPS lines and we have
a number of different methods to do that
they can be virus based or mRNA based
but typically we will look for an
external provider to help us generate
our IPS from a somatic cell okay and
this gets to the number of each time
through so just add I think if you can
do things with yeah as they improved I
think if you can generate your IPS cells
I think if you can do that without
integrating anything genomic into the
DNA that's a huge advantage so it is the
same I think I think most of the
technologies do that now and keep them
feeder free as well okay Brandon another
question for you here there are many
reports in the literature that IPS
cultures derived from disease patients
may behave differently to their healthy
control counterparts and this particular
user is wondering if you see differences
in the ability of healthy and diseased
IPS to generate your desired
orgonite types I think the answer is yes
I think when you're taking patient
derived cells if you're if you're just
taking the native patient cells then you
can see variation and I think some of
that can come from the patient
themselves with the disease they have a
lot of it can come from the method
that's used to generate those IPS cells
so I think that overcome that I think
patient derived cells are very important
but I would certainly advocate the use
of precise genome editing technologies
to make isogenic pairs of those cells
and by that I mean so either taking a
native cell and mutating the gene of
interest or taking your patient cell and
then mutating if it's a mononuclear
disease that gene back and i think there
you have the perfect control because
it's isagenix so the only thing that's
changed is the G's you've changed
I appreciate with a lot
diseases they're not monogenic and so
that's difficult to apply but I think if
you can get isogenic controls perfect if
you're going from patient derive
material I think what you will need to
do is you would need to have a number of
cells from the patient so both from the
same patient maybe of nr.3 from the same
patient and also from different patients
to show that your results are
reproducible across a number of lines
from a number of patients I think that's
what you would need to do okay we have
somebody would like to know if your your
organoids can be expanded indefinitely
or do you need to continuously
reinitiate them from your IPS C's s so
they cannot be grown indefinitely so we
we can take them out so we've shown them
that we can culture them so I guess they
go into organ wood formation on day 12
we've taken them to day 50 you do see
changes over that time course and you do
see maturation but it's not indefinite
culture you will see deterioration after
a while and so we we have routine
generations so every every couple of
weeks we will start a new round of
generating these organoids okay from the
the drug discovery work that you've
shown with wondered if there's any
evidence to date that shows that your
organized work is actually generating
higher quality and candidate drugs I
think that's too early to say I think
for the reasons I've given I can
understand why would they be more
predictive at that you see better
functionality better prediction I think
unfortunately because of the length of
time the drug discovery process takes so
to going from developing a molecule
taking it through discovery development
and then into the clinic I don't believe
we've seen data yet whereby a molecule
has been developed and discovered in a
3d system and gone into man so I think
there is no data there yet that would
confirm that but it would be my belief
that we will see that eventually some of
the work that you described Ryan involve
the use of
organoid to look at parameters such as
drug clearance how familiar are the
regulators with organoid technology and
do they accept experimental data derived
using organoids to be substituted for
classical tests or is this simply an
additional layer of data that's being
provided unfortunate as I guess on their
level of awareness my belief talking to
our discovery safety metabolism
colleagues is that I do believe they are
becoming more away where I do believe
certainly in the safety space we are
seeing data that is showing better
prediction from 3d organoids and this
can be in the kidney space with drug
clearance but also in the cardiac space
with cardiac organoids I think there is
a growing body of evidence that from an
in vitro prediction point of view we are
seeing better prediction when you move
from 2d to 3d so I believe they are
aware of it how close the art of
acceptance or substitution is a
different question and then I guess
ultimately what you would like to see is
that the increased use of these in vitro
models and a reduced use of in vivo
models but again you'd have to prove
that these are at least as predictive as
other models before doing that so I
think it it's possibly an extra layer at
the moment but I think the ultimate aim
is it's a it is a reduced layer and a
reduced number of assays and a reduced
amount of in vivo work ok we have
several questions actually rana which i
guess are heading towards the cell
therapy space you've described
essentially the use of organoids
in the drug discovery workflow but we
have several people here wondering if
AstraZeneca has ambitions to use
organoids or cells as the cell therapy
itself
what I can comment on is that from
within AstraZeneca we do have an
interest in in stem cell therapy and I
think if you take a look at our website
you can see our press releases on that
and we have certainly programs in the
cardiac space using stem cells as a as a
cell therapy so what I would say is that
we definitely do have an interest in
stem cell therapy the application of all
the noise is an interesting question but
not one I can answer at the moment okay
you've touched at the beginning of your
presentation on a number of different
organized types we have one user here
who's interested to know if there are 3d
skin organoids I'd have to apologize I'm
not sure if there are and skin is not a
pro lovin area for us so I don't have
much focus there so I wouldn't be able
to answer that accurately I apologize
now I think there are since a number of
years I think there are some skin models
which require liquid air interface is
actually four four four color
of models and I guess enough of
wound-healing I guess you see that and I
think in the 3d printing space I think
you see quite a lot of skin models so I
think it's only not only for the use in
pharmaceutical but I think of the
cosmetic area huge disease a lot as well
so whether it's an organized but
certainly some 3d models in the skin I'm
aware of but but I'm not an expert in
that area ok I think we have time for
one more question actually Ryan soil
it's a fairly simple question here but
we have a novice who'd like to
understand how large these organoids can
actually get they can get pretty big I
am so we can make organoids at different
sizes so in the publication so I've
talked about organoids of 1000 cells in
the publication we have organoids there
of a hundred thousand cells at a hundred
thousand cells and we're still not
seeing necrosis in the middle so the
organized how we call to them they're
looking nice and there will be a finite
point I think whereby you're stopping
nutrients getting to the center that may
be of benefit if you're thinking about a
cancer sphere a cancer organoid when you
want to see hypoxia in the middle so I
think there will be some limiting
factors about how big your organ we can
go and they may be good or bad features
we have taken hours to a hundred
thousand in size and they look ok I
presume you can go bigger but we haven't
looked at that ok lovely
Orion thanks very much again for the
presentation and for taking so many
questions and I'd also like to thank the
audience for taking the time to listen
in
before we go please note that today's
webinar will be available for on-demand
viewing through to February 2009 and
thanks very much again for everybody for
joining us today and we hope that you
enjoy the rest of today's event so as of
now this presentation will close thank
you very much indeed